oh she gets to oisi this is all whoa
this is fantastic
yeah that's bad this is one of the most
detailed toys I've ever seen in my life
oh that is job dude welcome to what's in
the box I'm your excellent host Wayne
Campbell
Garth party on Wayne party on Garth okay
man the object of this game very simple
find out what's in the box what's in the
box
[Music]
eggs dude yes yes the alien queen dude
this is fantastic
NECA and real toys man have got a some
special this week that spits out the
eggs it's got the whale in you tani like
a little logo on and stuff it's got
nutrition facts on it but it says it
says contains six eggs not for human
consumption okay it also says I'm very
confused
cause this is choking us I guess we
shouldn't eat it is the point here we go
opening it up that is dope dude it's a
fleshlight
yes that's taken to prevent an
infestation or practition keep all
living organisms away from the eggs
discard broken cracked open eggs and run
far far as our eggs contain facehuggers
which are most certainly bad for your
health do not look directly into the egg
look at this watch this
oh yeah I remember the scene in the
movie when they opened the egg and I had
a plastic bag in it and then they opened
the plastic bag and add a face hugger
look that's Tigers got a wire his tail
so you can bend it and stuff you can
wear it like an area or a blue tooth
look at this come on yes when you were a
kid man you pray for something this bad
it's like please Jesus send me an alien
egg with a face higher coming out of it
and Jesus never listened and that's why
I gave up religion and to say the view
look at that clothes brown I'm saying
dude that looks like wow this is not for
children or particularly not any boys
who are entering puberty because they're
gonna be like what's that together
gauger you go design the eggs to look
even more like vaginas than they do that
was his idea
somebody was like don't you think these
look a little like live vaginas I wanted
to look a lot and they got back in and
redesigned I've seen some gauger
pictures there's wieners and boobs ever
come in man was a genius purposefully in
scale so they fit on the faces of these
figures and can totally rewrite alien
history and have that facehugger attack
grizzly in the first movie changes the
whole franchise completely mint and
these you know the eggs are called
technically within the alien universe oh
look at that
that thing it's heavy right this is one
myself
yesterday I should open the doors and
get away from her you [ __ ] and look
these things move like yes how come they
haven't invented this yet the power
loader in a world where we have Iron Man
movies how come we can't have this in
real life I think we could I know the
parallel doesn't make sense but what
degree that's try to fit her and I
straddle that school and you could put
her Reeboks I remember when this movie
came out man she was wearing Reeboks and
there was an ad for him and they built a
marketing campaign around the futuristic
Reeboks
[Music]
there we go baby impressive
bust out that big girl yeah yeah where
you want it I am a huge man Oh huge huge
fan of this movie man
I saw this in a theater in 1986 how come
that I have a new figure man that's what
I was looking forward to what you say
new they mostly come at night okay man
we've opened up everything
this alien place that comes with
everything you see here look at all this
beautiful stuff this is one of the most
detailed toys I've ever seen in my life
well this is her from the first movie
that start from the second movie so if
they ever did inhaling time-travel she
couldn't fight herself then they could
also cross over with ghostbusters she'd
be like there is no Dana only Zuul yeah
you gotta use the line if you're gonna
hit Ripley with Ripley you have to say
get away from her you [ __ ] and then get
away from our parents not not [ __ ] you
[ __ ] get away from her you [ __ ] just
like the movie is at the end of the
first movie when she was in the suit
trying to escape the alien or kill the
alien this is the depressed she cut her
hair for all this is Ripley realizing
like I've been in space a long time man
yeah she just suggests yeah in space no
one can hear you sigh this is my
favorite part right here as a cat lover
come on do they got Jonesy the cat
Jonesy one action
and one is chillin and the heads move
look at that there's articulation on the
cap that if only the paws weren't up
they can go that is crazy dude they can
move their heads all around just like a
real cat they only go like I mean turn
around and have her lick her own leg
back let me clean myself right away your
first thing is like articulation means a
cat can lick its own ass right the tail
moves too like this somebody's trying
they're going like you know whatever
every kid's favorite part of this is
gonna be the cat's tail and he made it
move get away from her you [ __ ] she
flips turn goes like this bread's she
picks her up his heels but she's in the
shop and she throws her yeah yeah this
job Seattle and she goes down an inch do
you then they go down together and then
somehow this woman opens up a giant
airlock in space
and holds on to a ladder it doesn't go
flying out the only part of aliens that
doesn't make sense yeah everything else
says except that that didn't make sense
at all
what is this what is that you know what
that is Manus that's the screwdriver do
is literally for shipping for ship in
the allele at worst case scenario you
don't got this gear just like now there
this is the shower shipping Ripley
figure man for when she goes to jail
Layla's a newt and he puts her in jail
she blew up the ship and she's like I'll
go to jail as long as I got my shift no
I think this is this made-up ID what do
you mean e ID what do they call that for
the ladies you know my movie I love this
movie so I love seeing this stuff but
look at the articulation of this I
really do like these two give this to a
kid man and terrify them forever give
them to the right kid but look at that
let's figure out how much this stuff
would come that's what I was just
thinking price-wise we think alike all
right here we go man what would you be
willing to pay for the power loader P
5000 deluxe a vehicle toy do I love the
movie or I just think do you love the
culture I know it's not Waterworld but
do you like this movie I like the movie
not a I don't love it like a lot of
other people but I do like this too
you're putting more thought into this
character than you've ever put into any
of the times I've made a movie in terms
of like just come up with a number what
do you alright the number I would slash
$24.99 you'd be wrong you got four times
that by four add a little more one
hundred and nine dollars one hundred and
ten Yeah right now this is new this
being a hundred and ten what do you
think the alien queen is now how much
would you pay for this $49.99 this is
under 10 that's $49.99 yeah I'm thinking
this has a lot more detail it says
moving parts but this has main
characters the alien I don't go by that
I go by the work in the craftsmanship
even in craftsmanship as you call it
without the eyes look at all of that
craftsmanship look at this house crazy
she's got four sets of arms the big hood
the tail she can lay on the tail
now that's 110 how much could that fuss
now I'd say it's sixty nine nine nine
Jesus no dude it's close to the price of
that oddly enough - ten bucks less man
this is ninety nine hundred dollars for
the alien queen they charge you ten
bucks more for
loader without a fit you know why
because just comes with all this this
rubber alone is ten bucks
so each figure I would say basically
$14.99 no this is I forgot the old
bigger figures cost more so let's say 25
plus uns I forgot bigger figures called
okay $24.99 bigger figures costs more
you're close to 20 $1.99 for Ripley from
aliens of 1999 for the rest of them
except for the eggs we haven't done the
eggs how much think the carton eggs goes
well with the exits how much is a real
card let's see how let's see if you
couldn't deal in the real world what is
a real carton of eggs cost $4.99 you're
wrong it's easily like I want to say if
they're organic 229 you know what I'm
thinking I'm thinking about you thinking
great a big brown large I'm thinking I'm
literally blown prices when I worked at
quick stuff which is 20 years ago I
thought yes oh yeah anybody I buy eggs
but thanks thanks $4.99 for real eggs
how much of fake eggs $9.99 $25.99 but
look at these face huggers man you're
kidding I'd buy it a go home my wife
would be like you're an [ __ ] I'd be
like no I'm not I've dreamed of having
this my whole life and I have it that
makes me the winner
I go to my room not play with it for
three seconds put on a shelf argue about
it for 10 years
this can be W such triple usage what you
got store things that's why I put my
rings about here yeah and then this verb
I put my yam bag some good lordy look at
this it has a fake expiration date or
real on June 3rd 21 22 so you have a toy
that won't go bad in your lifetime
guarantee
hats off to NECA as we say as I say when
I wake up my wife's like what you just
said it comes off Tanaka that's how I
wake up hats off to NECA because look at
this this is crap we dreamed about
I had the Kenner alien doll which I only
got out of someone's garbage when I was
a kid cuz my parents weren't rich enough
or loved me enough to buy me my own but
somebody threw one of the PNR aliens up
and didn't go yeah if you pulled it no
it didn't do that
yeah wait again no it didn't do that but
now I want to make a Jason Mewes figure
where you're squeezing me oh yeah
no man it had the mouth you squeezing
the mouth would come out and stuff I'm
an this even though this doesn't have
the energy oz that come out this is
still far superior torque to that Kenner
version Kenner gets the nostalgia win
but this alien queen by NECA
one of finest toys ever Mary in fact one
of the best uses of plastic since a
vibrator right here man doesn't give as
much pleasure as a vibrator but there
you go it's also weight point here and
sharper than my ribs you know what the
vibrator analogy doesn't really work at
all my bad there's kids man this week in
the box nothing but aliens love all over
us man thanks to the good folks in mecca
for making this fine looking product man
and thanks you guys for tuning in and
watching us open this stuff up once
these open up other things and stuff
tell us what they're so sweet want to
see us open up on them thanks yeah tell
us what you want to see us open up man
go to Twitter hit the screen junkies out
go to screen junkies Facebook page and
I'm up there email them if you must get
us your message is we will find you I
feel like Daniel day-lewis them in that
movie we will find you tell us what you
want to see and we'll find out what's in
the box man until then I'm Kevin Smith
Jason Mewes next week on what's in the
box what's in the box get away from her
you [ __ ]
No
[Music]
you
you